F
SOUTH CAROLINA TONIGHT
THANK YOU.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
STORM.
WE HAVE BREAKING NEWS,
WHISTLE-BLOWERS ARE NOW COMING
FORWARD TO OHIO CONGRESSMAN JUST
LIKE THEY HAVE BEEN A CHARLES
PRESLEY AND RON JOHNSON.
THEY ARE ALLEGING THAT YOUR FBI
AS WE HAVE BEEN TALKED ABOUT A
LOT HAS NOW BEEN COMPLETELY
POLITICIZED AND NOW TRYING TO
EVEN PURGE ANY CONSERVATIVE
EMPLOYEES.
THEY WRITE A LETTER TO A SENIOR
FBI HUMAN RESOURCE OFFICIAL THAT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS HAVE ALLEGED
THAT THE AGENCY NOW IS REVOKING
THE SECURITY CLEARANCES OF
CONSERVATIVE EMPLOYEES AND EVEN
OUTRIGHT SUSPENDING THEM.
THE FBI'S TELLING FOX NEWS IN A
STATEMENT THAT THE FBI DOES NOT
TARGET, OR TAKE ADVERSE ACTION
AGAINST ANY EMPLOYEES FOR
EXERCISING THE FIRST OF THEM AND
WRITES.
OR FOR THE POLITICAL VIEWS,
OKAY, IF THAT IS TRUE THEN WHY
DOES THE ATTORNEY GENERAL I'M
ARGUING IS WEAPONIZING THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE
MERRICK GARLAND.
WHY IS HE TRYING TO STOP THE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS IN THE FBI FROM
TALKING TO MEMBERS OF CONGRESS?
YOU MIGHT REMEMBER, HE SENT OUT
THAT LITTLE MEMO AFTER
DONALD TRUMP SAID WE HAVE OVER
20 WHISTLE-BLOWERS LAST MONTH.
HE SCENTED THE DOJ EMPLOYEES
REMINDING THEM THAT NO
DEPARTMENT, EMPLOYEE MAY
COMMUNICATE WITH MEMBERS OF
CONGRESS OR CONGRESSIONAL STAFF
WITHOUT ADVANCE APPROVAL FROM
THE OFFICE OF LEGISLATIVE
AFFAIRS.
IS HE TRYING TO INTIMIDATE THESE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS AND TESTS
SILENCE?
JIM JORDAN.
IT SOUNDS TO ME I THOUGHT WE HAD
WHISTLE-BLOWER LAWS, I THOUGHT
WE LIKE THEM WE PUT HEARSAY
WHISTLE-BLOWERS ON A PEDESTAL.
FBI WHISTLE-BLOWERS ARE BEING
TOLD TO SHUT UP THEY'RE NOT
ALLOWED TO TALK TO LIKES OF YOU,
THAT'S HOW I INTERPRET IT.
>> NO, YOU'RE EXACTLY RIGHT THAT
IS THE LAW SEAN AND IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE FOLLOWED.
I THINK IT'S INTERESTING TO
POINT THIS OUT.
A FEW WEEKS AGO WHEN I WAS ON
YOUR SHOW WE TALKED ABOUT THE 14
WHISTLE-BLOWERS COME FBI AGENTS
COME TO OUR OFFICE THE VERY NEXT
DAY.
THE VERY NEXT DAY
MERRICK GARLAND SUNSET MEMOIR
SAYING HERE ARE THE RULES IF
YOU'RE IN A SPEECH TO CONGRESS.
IT WAS A MEMO DESIGNED TO CHILL
THE SPEECH OF BRAVE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS WHO WANT TO COME
FORWARD AND TELLS THE TRUTH.
WE ALSO KNOW THAT SOME OF THOSE
WHISTLE-BLOWERS HAVE HAD THEIR
SECURITY CLEARANCE REVOKED.
WHICH IS ALWAYS THE FIRST STEP
IN TERMINATING SOMEONE AT THE
FBI AND NOW WE THINK THAT THERE
IS IMMENSE A BIT RETALIATION
AGAINST WHISTLE-BLOWER WHO HAS
BEEN SUSPENDED AND THIS IS ONE
OF THE VERY FIRST
WHISTLE-BLOWERS WE HAVE THAT'S
BEEN SUSPENDED.
HE CAME TO US BACK LAST FALL THE
SCHOOL BOARD ISSUE WE LEARN THAT
MEMO RANDOMLY CAME FROM
ATTORNEY GENERAL GARLAND
DESIGNED TO SAVE WORK AND
INSTITUTE COUNTERTERRORISM GETS
MOMS AND DADS AT 20 SOME PARENTS
INVESTIGATED BY THE FBI FOR
SIMPLE SHOWING UP THE SCHOOL
BOARD MEETING SO CONTINUES TO
ESCALATE AND THEM AND VIEWED IN
CONTEXT OF EVERYTHING WERE
DEALING WITH THIS IS FINDING
STUFF.
>> Sean: AM HEARING AS MANY AS
30 WHISTLE-BLOWERS JEWISH SEVEN
LETTER THEY RECEIVED PROTECTIVE
WHISTLE-BLOWER DISCLOSURES IF
THE FIS ENGAGING IN HIS PURGE OF
CONSERVATIVES.
NOW THERE ARE TWO THINGS
SEEMINGLY GOING ON
SIMULTANEOUSLY, YOUR PURGING
CONSERVATIVES, SILENCING THEM,
NOW MERRICK GARLAND HAS
INTIMIDATING THEM BASICALLY
SAYING YOU'RE NOT ALLOWED TO
TALK TO ELECTED OFFICIALS THAT
WOULD CONTRADICT IN MY OPINION
WHISTLE-BLOWER PROTECTION LAWS,
THEY ARE SAYING NOT ONLY HAS
BEEN POLITICIZED, NOW IT'S A
PURGING SO WHAT IS GOING ON WITH
OUR DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE?
WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE WHEN WE
GET TO THE BOTTOM OF IT, BECAUSE
OF THAT IS THE CASE OUT EXPLAIN
WHY WE DON'T HAVE EQUAL JUSTICE
OR EQUAL APPLICATION LAWS IN OUR
COUNTRY WHICH WOULD SCARE THE
HELL OUT OF EVERY AMERICAN.
>> I THINK IT'S ALL DESIGNED THE
PLAN IS ALL DESIGNED TO FIT THIS
NARRATIVE THAT JOE BIDEN IS LAID
OUT THERE AT THE COUNTRY ARE
FASCIST AND EXTREMIST, THIS
CRAZY CLAIM THAT HE IS MADE AND
NOW THEY HAVE TO AS THEY SAY
JUICE THE NUMBERS WE'VE HAD SOME
WHISTLE-BLOWERS TALK ABOUT THAT
ANOTHER GETTING PRESSURE TO
LABEL ALL CASES AS
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EXTREMISTS TO
JUICE THE NUMBERS AND COOK THE
BOOKS BECAUSE THE WAY THAT THEIR
CAT CATALOGUING THESE CASES TO
MAKE IT APPEAR THAT THEY ARE
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE EXTREMISTS ALL
OVER THE COUNTRY.
ALL THE FIT THIS NARRATIVE MAY
NOT SEE IT MANIFEST WE HAVE A
WEEK AGO.
SO THAT SEEMS TO BE WHAT THEY
ARE UP TO AND OF COURSE IF YOU
HAVE CONSERVATIVE, IF YOU HAVE
FBI AGENTS OR FOLLOWING THE LAW
AND DOING WITH HER SUPPOSED TO
THEY'RE KNOCKING TO GO ALONG
WITH THAT, THAT IS WHY THEY'RE
COMING TO US AND THEY ARE TRYING
TO STOP THEM TO COME FORWARD TO
GIVE US THE TRUTH.
>> Sean: WE ARE NOW 40 DAYS
OUT FROM THE ELECTION AND WE
HAVE MORE JANUARY 6 HEARINGS IN
THE LEAD UP TO THE ELECTION.
WE KNOW THAT EVERYONE ON THE
COMMITTEE HAS A POLITICAL BIAS
THAT'S FINE THEY'RE ALLOWED TO
HAVE THEIR OPINIONS.
THEY IGNORE THE 574 RIOTS THAT
ENTERED THOUSANDS OF COBS,
BRICKS, ROCKS, BOTTLES, MOLOTOV
COCKTAILS.
THEY IGNORE THE FACT THAT THOSE
574 RIOTS A LOT OF DEMOCRATS
SAID WERE MOSTLY PEACEFUL AND
ENCOURAGED BY THE OF
KAMALA HARRIS BY THE WAY
TWEETING OUT SUPPORT FOR A BAIL
FUND.
APPRAISING DEFINING THE L.A.P.D.
WE HAD BILLIONS OF PROPERTY
DAMAGE AND DOZENS OF DEAD
AMERICANS, WHERE'S THAT
COMMITTEE INVESTIGATING THOSE
RIOTS BY LEFT-WING GROUPS?
>> OR SEAN, THE DOZENS, DOZENS
OF PRO-LIFE CRISIS PREGNANCY
CENTERS THAT WERE ATTACKED IN
THE AFTERMATH OF LEAKING THE
DRAFT OPINIONS AND THE CHURCH IS
OUR VANDALIZE IN THE AFTERMATH
OF LEAKING A DRAFT OPINION.
WHERE ARE THOSE INVESTIGATIONS?
HOW CAN WE DON'T HEAR ABOUT
THOSE?
ARE THE RATING WITH 20 FBI
AGENTS ARE THOSE KIND OF PLACES
FOR THE PEOPLE WHO DID THAT HARM
LIKE IT DID TO THIS PASTOR
OUTSIDE OF PHILADELPHIA?
SO THAT IS THE THING THAT
BOTHERS SOME THE AMERICAN
FAMILIES AND I THINK THAT THEY
ARE BEEN A MEMBER THAT WHEN THEY
GO TO VOTE IN 40 DAYS.